قال الدفاع المدني في جنوب لبنان ان رجلين
وامراه استشهدوا فجر اليوم في غاره
اسرائيليه استهدفت منزلا في بلده بنت جبيل
وفاد مراسل الجزيره ايضا باطلاق 12 صاروخا
من جنوب لبنان باتجاه مواقع عسكريه في
مزارع شبع المحتله والجليل الاعلى كان حزب
الله اللبناني قد اعلن امس مهاجمته تسعه
مواقع اسرائيليه مشيرا الى انه استلف
بطائره مسيره مقر قياده عسكريه في محيط
مست طنه كريات شمونه كما هاجم عده تجمعات
لجنود الاحتلال مؤكدا سقوط قتلى وجرحى
اسرائيليين من جتها قالت مصادر اسرائيليه
انها رصدت اطلاق عشر قذائف من لبنان على
مواقع عسكريه الاسرائيليه في مزال الشبع
ولم تبلغ او تبلغ عن اصابات او
اضرار كان المتحدث العسكري باسم الجيش
الاسرائيلي دانييل الجاري قد اعلن مقتل
جندي واصابه تسعه اخر
نتيجه اطلاق صاروخ مضاد للدروع قرب قريه
جريث شمالي اسرائيل يوم امس ورجح الجيش
الاسرائيلي ان عناصر من حزب الله نصبوا
كمينا للجنود بعد استهدافهم الموقع مرتين
بصواريخ مضاده للدروع وقال ان عده قذائف
اطلقت من جنوب لبنان باتجاه مازال الشبع
المحتله دون اصابات بالمقابل اعلن الجيش
مهاجمته اهدافا لحزب
الله
للمتابعه ينضم الينا من بلده بنت جبيل
جنوب لبنان مدير مكتب الجزيره مازن
ابراهيم كما ستنضم الينا من الجليل الاعلى
مراسله الجزيره فاطمه خمايسي ابدا معك
مازن وابرز التطورات في بنت
جبيل دعنا نبدا من هذا المشهد الذي بات
يتكرر في اكثر من قريه جنوبيه لبنانيه على
طول الخط الحدودي هذه هي مخلفات طائرات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وقد اغارت في ساعه
متاخره من مساء يوم امس على هذا المنزل
نتحدث عن منزلين هنا في هذه المنطقه في
احد احياء بلده بنت جبيل وهذا ما خلفه ال
العدوان الاسرائيلي من خلال الطائرات التي
تطلق صواريخها باتجاه منازل المدنيين في
ساعه متاخره نحو منتصف الليل كان هنالك
اغاره من طائره مقاتله حربيه اسرائيل
بصاروخين على هذا المبنى مما ادى الى
استشهاد ثلاثه اشخاص نتحدث عن شقيقين
وزوجه احدهما استشهدوا في هذه في هذا
المنزل تحديدا عندما قامت طائرات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي باطلاق صواريخها يمكن ان نشاهد
حجم الدمار الكبير الذي خلفه خلفته هذه
الغاره في هنا عند هذه ال هذا هذه الحاره
في بلده بنت جبيل حيث اقف كان مبنى مؤلف
من طابقين يمكن ان نرى حجم القوه
التدميريه التي تستخدمها اسرائيل في اطلاق
الصواريخ باتجاه منازل المدنيين هنا في
بلده بنت جبال هذا المشهد الذي تشاهده هنا
يتكرر في عشرات القرى والبلدات
اللبنانيه منذ نحو شهرين حيث تقوم طائرات
الاحتلال باطلاق صواريخها وايضا القذائف
المدفعيه والقنابل الحارقه في اكثر من
موضع وهذا ما كنا نرصده طيله الاسابيع
الماضيه الذي حصل هنا عند منتصف الليل تم
اطلاق الصواريخ باتجاه هذا المنزل سارعت
فرق الدفاع المدني المتواجده في هذه
المنطقه في محاوله لانتشال من كان يتواجد
في هذا المنزل نتحدث عن اسره الوالد كان
هنا مع ابنين واضافه الى زوجه ابنه استشهد
على الفور ثلاثه من افراد العائله اما قوه
الانفجار فقد رمت الوالد من احد الشفات
هنا في هذه النقطه الى الخارج ولم يصب
باذى يمكن ان نعاين حجم الدمار الكبير
الذي خلفته هذه الغاره ليس فقط ضمن هذا
المنزل ولكن ضمن مربع سكني في هذه المنطقه
التي تم استهدافها من قبل الطائرات
الاسرائيليه يمكن ان نشاهد حتى الان هنا
بعض
مخلفات الصواريخ التي اطلقت كما يمكن ان
نرى في الخلفيه مجلس عزاء اقيم على من قبل
العائله عائله الاشخاص الذين استشهدوا في
هذه الغاره الاسرائيليه الذي رصدناه طيله
اليوم الماضي مجموعه كبيره من العمليات
التي نفذها حزب الله على طول الخط الحدودي
وهو ما قابلته اسرائيل باطلاق صواريخها
باتجاه المناطق السكنيه كما نشاهد هنا في
بلده بنت جبال هذا الامر امتد على اكثر من
قريه واكثر من بلده كان هنالك مجموعه من
الغارات التي نفذتها طائرات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي في اكثر من منطقه في جنوب
لبنان وصلت الى عمق يتراوح اكثر من 20 كم
في العمق الجنوبي اذا ما قيس هذا الامر من
داخل من الحدود الجنوبيه للبنان من خط
الازرق وصولا الى محافظه النبطيه حيث تم
استهداف احدى البلدات في تلك المنطقه
عمليا هذا المشهد هذا الدمار بات يتكرر
يوميا حيث باتت الحدود الجنوبيه للبنان
اشبه بساحه حرب مفتوحه وهذا الامر يحصل
منذ اسابيع نتحدث عن اكثر من شهرين
وعمليات القصف الاسرائيلي تستمر وتخلف كل
هذا الضرر نتحدث عن اكثر من 25 شهيدا من
المدنيين سقطوا في جراء اطلاق الصواريخ من
قبل قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بالاضافه
الى سقوط اكثر من 120 شهيدا لحزب الله
الذي عاهم في بيانات طيله الشهرين
الماضيين من خلال العمليات العسكريه التي
كان ينفذها وهنا لابد من الاشاره الى ان
المعادله التي ارتسمت خلال المرحله
الاخيره والتي كان قد اعلن عنها حزب الله
بان اي استهداف للمدنيين اللبنانيين
سيقابل باستهداف المستوطنين الاسرائيليين
وهو ما بتنا نشهده من خلال الاستهدافات
والصواريخ المتكرره التي باتت تطلق باتجاه
المستوطنات الاسرائيليه واخرها ما حصل من
خلال العمليات التي حصلت يوم امس وسجلت
اكثر من تسع عمليات عسكريه نفذها حزب الله
مازن ابراهيم مدير مكتب الجزيره من بنت
جبيل جنوب لبنان اشكرك ا